recording in progress and simply learn
to get ahead Jess Danish a civil
engineer turned data scientist who
decided to Simply learn
possible with a course from a premier
[Music]
University true champion who upskilled
to win
big how big a massive hike that
transformed my life Danish Chang gears
pretty early in the race but pron wanted
to explore more to get
ahead simply learn from mechanical
engineering to a data analyst and a
podcaster in his free time career
transformation bro simply learn indust
expert dat
expert with a well structured course it
felt like a piece of cake that is simply
awesome what's also awesome is that long
nathin didn't choose a quick fix he just
added data science into the
mix nithan how did you change the game
worked on real industry problems to
become the real deal a joint family a
regular job responsibilities but nothing
could stop Nan from getting ahead what
an allrounder de Hoya night with
flexible learning you can always make it
right passing your
situation you will find your way to get
ahead when you simply
learn simply learn get ahead with simply
[Music]
learn
uh hello everyone uh so we'll be
starting the session right on time in
few minutes uh meanwhile uh let's have a
quick round of introductions here on
chat here uh so I'm Rasha Khan I'm
joining from all the way from Bangalore
India I'm thrilled to be your host today
uh drop us a hello and let us know where
are you tuning in from and let the
global conversations begin um I can see
introductions already have started
coming in on chat here I can see uh
Louis has joined from Nigeria I can see
ver has joined from
Thailand uh I can
see okay okay okay okay I can see Rohit
has joined Rohit Bas has joined uh I
think RIT you need mention where you're
joining from but I can see you written
you're a cyber crime and forensic
investigator so that's great good to
have folks you know who can also share
insights you know while be having an
interesting conversation with Rohit who
has already joined us here uh I can see
VI has joined from Bangalore I can see
uh okay I can see viin has joined from
Bangalore as well I can see goind has
joined from Chennai I can see abijit
from India uh where in India would love
to know uh okay Rohit Rohit has
mentioned has joined from Ki I can see
umir has joined from Pakistan I can see
Guru has joined from
Chennai um Samuel has joined from South
Sudan and push has joined from
Hyderabad I can see folks have joined
from Tang so welcome everyone welcome uh
to the session uh we'll be starting in
few minutes meanwhile why not let
Network a bit right why not introduce
your yourself on chart here so it's a
good way to network right these events
so before we start we have few minut
more minutes uh you can get settled in
uh wherever you're joining us from and
also you can let us know a quick
introduction mentioning your name and
where are you joining us from so I can
see a lot of introductions coming in on
chat here so that's great we've gotten a
really active audience
here and I can see a lot of folks have
joined from different different parts of
India and even outside of India as well
I can see uh Krishna has joined from
England okay I can can see tapen has
joined from West Bengal I can see
someone is joined from Pakistan and
nagaland so really really good uh you
know folks from joining from different
different parts of the world so that's
great keep the introductions coming in
I'll just put down my introduction once
again here so I'm Rasha Khan I will be
your host for today's webinar and I'm
joining from Bangalore India would love
to know where are you joining us
from I see a lot of new folks are just
joining in so uh um so we'll just wait
for like two three minutes more before
we start the session um before we start
maybe let let me take you through a few
ground rules we have for the session uh
so uh if you have any question uh
related to cyber security in general or
about the program you can put down your
questions in the Q&A box so the Q&A box
is just beside the chart box where we we
have having a conversation right now
where people are giving introductions uh
so you can just locate it you know just
beside the chat box um by am I telling
that you need to put on your your
questions in the QA box because we get a
lot of messes on chat here and we might
miss it and we want to make sure that we
address all of your queries here so just
help me with that just put down your
questions in the Q&A box I'm pretty sure
you have come with a mindset of
basically you joining a cyber security
career or you are aspiring for it so
please make sure that you put on your
questions in the Q&A box and about the
session recording this session is being
recorded so in case you want to go
through the recording of the session
again you can expect a followup email
with the recording link webinar
certificate and also a bonus offer for
attending this webinar for the program
part which will be coming up next also
uh to request a proof of attendance for
this webinar uh you need to enter your
full name in the post webinar survey so
what is the post webinar survey so when
the session ends this session is of 160
minutes duration uh so when the session
ends you'll be getting a post webinar
popup where you can enter your full name
there'll be an option for that and also
feedback for us you know how we can make
our webinars better so uh moving on uh
we the agenda of the session we'll be
talking about cyber security careers in
general and we'll be talking about the
cyber security program what exactly it
offers and how this program gets your
job ready and enrollment steps and the
Q&A part so um we'll try to take as many
questions as possible throughout the
session uh but just in case we are not
able to take your questions so please
don't worry about that have a little
patience uh just put on your questions
in the Q&A box and we'll take those
questions just keep it relevant to cyber
security
okay while I was speaking I see a lot of
introductions here uh I can see Shi
Prasad has joined us from Hyderabad I
can see Vijay from Mumbai Dharma from
Bangalore Asam H has joined us from Pune
a passionate cyber security professional
forj I think you are in the right
session then we have gotten a really
amazing speaker here with us
roama okay uh I'll just quickly put down
few things which I just spoke about so
uh for the webinar certificate you need
to stay till the end of the session in
order to get the certificate so I'm just
putting that down for you here and also
about the recording of the session uh as
I said we will be getting the recording
of the session uh post webinar over a
followup email so in case you want to go
through the recording once
again awesome uh this program is powered
by simply world's number one online boot
camp we are very proud that we have been
in the Dig space of skills training for
almost 13 years now and we have trained
over 5 million press Professionals in
over 150 plus countries and uh we are
very proud that we are transforming
lives or empowering people by via
digital
skills we already have our speaker here
with us Rohit tamama uh Rohit where are
you joining us
from hey Rasha can you hear me now yes
yes yeah hey Rasha good evening to you
and good evening to all of you um first
of all thank you for having me today I'm
joining in from Hyderabad awesome
awesome uh I think before we start uh
let's get to know you a little better so
you can see a quick poll on your screen
right now uh so we would love to know
like how how many years of experience do
you currently have so you can see four
quick options here here a poll has been
launched
uh you can select one option which is
the most suitable for you I can just
I'll just quickly read out the options
for you as well if you're currently
studying you can select the first one if
you have zero to three is of experience
you can select the second one and if you
have three to five is of experience you
can select the third one and the last
one if you have more than five years of
experience in case the PLL does not
cover uh how many years of experience do
you have you can let us know on chat
here as well so this will just give us
an idea you know what kind of folks you
know what kind of experience they coming
from who have joined us I can see the
polls were already moving in while I was
speaking and I can see almost 80% of the
folks have already shared their
responses so I think we' have gotten a
really active audience here and uh
they're very excited about the session
Ro I can see that a lot of cyber
security you know aspirants and people
who are passionate about it so I think
we'll just wait for 5 seconds more
before I
end the poll for a few of the folks who
have not shared with us quick poll on
the screen how much experience do you
currently
have okay I can see most of the folks
have already shared with us so I'll just
give five seconds more so 5 4 3 2 1 let
me quickly end the poll and also share
the results with you thank you so much
for sharing that with us so uh as we can
see that 43% of the folks who have
joined us are C study and uh 32% of the
folks have more than 5 years of
experience um a very balanced profile
ageny currently studying and more than 5
years of experience so we have gotten
all set of folks here and then I can see
then few of the folks have Z to three
years of experience and 3 to 5 years of
experience as well so again like thank
you once again for sharing that with us
now moving on uh I think I've already
introduced you to Rohit here but Rohit
would you like to give us your
introduction absolutely um thank you so
much Rasha so I have 14 years of
experience in the cyber security domain
I started in the cyber security domain
and I'm you know after spending for 14
years I'm kind of married to The Domain
now right so I'm looking forward to
having you know next whatever years in
the same space so um I started off with
uh with penetration tester role and I
have been in the security Assurance Spas
for the first 10 years so I was mostly
doing stuff like you know threat
modeling the applications performing
design reviews secure code reviews um
mostly from the point of view of how do
we take right um security measures to
build
uh secure applications and secure
products and then after 10 years I
thought you know I got interested in
understanding you know no matter how um
how much care you take in terms of
producing secure stuff things will
always break once they move to
production right and I I I I got
interested to know how do we detect and
respond to such kind of U you know cyber
attacks once they once uh the
applications are live in the production
so I moved to the security operation
space which is primarily about the
detection and incident response so I
have been spending the last four years
in that space uh and uh I also got my um
uh interest in other related domains for
example 4 and six is one of the very
interesting domains for me personally uh
so along with few of my colleagues uh
few years back we uh we we also authored
a couple of books related to Mobile for6
so this is specific to platforms like
Android and iOS and how do we extract
certain information out of those mobile
phones during forensic investigations so
that's a quick brief about me uh I'll
hand it back to you uh thank you so much
Rohit for amazing introduction that's
some year of experience like 14 plus
years of experience cyber security
definitely mared to The Domain I would
say and uh like before we move on to the
cyber security careers and talk more
about it have a conversation about it uh
wanted to know like uh where exactly did
you start in cyber security did you were
you always there in cyber security or uh
like basically how did you transition it
because a lot of folks who have joined
us will have a question that I'm coming
from this domain but I want to go to
cyber security domain uh is it hard is
it easy do I need to learn learn a lot
of technical skills all all those things
like can you tell us a little bit about
that in your journey yeah yeah I think
I'll cover both the topics right so in
my case you know I I started my career
in in cyber security so I was a campus
uh I was campus placed in TCS and when I
joined the TCS there were uh two two two
to three different roles that were
available one of them was the uh
programming or the engineering role
which is about you know learning code
and building applications the other was
around testing the applications and uh
the third one was around finding
vulnerabilities in in the applications
that people develop um so I was not very
much inclined towards the coding piece
back then and frankly those days I did
not have a complete understanding of the
cyber security space and even it was
just evolving at that time right but the
concept of you know U breaking into
application was something that you know
caught my attention uh you know it's
just the element of you know how do how
does somebody just without having a
credentials be able to log in to the
application so I went and spoke to the
manager who was recruiting for that role
and and uh I was told scenarios like
these right like uh our team tries to
find out what are different
ways hackers and attackers bypass the
applications so that problem statement
itself was uh something that was
intriguing for me and I thought you know
why not start in that space and I
thought if it doesn't work I I can think
of moving at a later point of time uh
but once I started you know I was really
uh interested and curious to know more
things uh within that space um so never
uh look back in terms of uh you know
considering a different domain but
having said that you know I think to to
answer your second part of the question
which is hey if I'm from a non-security
background um what are my chances of
moving into security background right I
I know there are many folks uh who might
be aspiring to do it right and and the
good news is U I can definitely tell you
that um you do not have to start your
career in cyber security if you want to
shape your career in the cyber security
space right in fact you know from my
experience uh some of the best people
that I have worked with in this industry
have all started from a non-security
background oh interesting yeah and I'll
tell you the reason as well right so I
for example I have worked with um few
people who started as programmers for
the first six to eight years they were
just programming right learning they
were writing applications in net or Java
or any other programming language uh but
somehow you know they moved into the
security domain but why uh I I think one
thing that came as came out as an
advantage for them is because they know
the inner workings of how the code works
if they have to perform a secure code
review of the applications they know
things better than anybody else right so
they are able to relate how the coding
piece connects back to the attackers
bypassing it or exploiting certain
vulnerabilities and and so on so it's
like you know you have a very solid
foundation that was built uh in the
first initial years and then if you look
at the same pivot from a security angle
you're able to connect the dots better
you're able to relate the things better
Etc um but but the key point there is to
see um what what are what is your
existing strength right for some people
it could be programming for some others
it could be networking background or for
some others it might be system
administration right and then you see
what is the most close relevant domain
in cyber security space that that you
could consider and build on top of the
existing skill set that you already have
um so long long answer but uh you know
to put it in simple words um wherever
you are right now or whatever role you
might have started in your career it is
always possible to see um uh you know
how do you uh you know change the course
into into cyber security
space oh that sounds pretty interesting
I think while you're speaking as well we
got a lot of similar questions I think
that answers question for folks coming
from a non- technical background or even
having a little bit you know experience
in you know code so I think we'll talk
more about it uh in basically U today's
topic of the session basically how you
can Skyrocket your cyber security career
in 2023 so before we start uh for folks
uh just to let you know that I'm pretty
sure you have a lot of questions you
know for roit here uh we'll try to cover
as many questions we have for Rohit in
this conversation uh but you can always
put down your questions in the Q&A box
so if you put on the question in the Q&A
box we will try to take it you know
during this conversation as well so let
us know and before we start uh so I
think the first question we can start
with as we look into the future Beyond
2023 what significant risk are we are
emerging in the realm of cyber security
and what are the Prevailing Trends
Rohit okay so let me break it down into
two pieces right so let's first talk
about what are we seeing in the last one
to two years which are the current
trends and then we'll also talk about
you know maybe in 2024 and in future
what could be the significant Trends um
so there are many but in the interest of
time you know I'll probably talk about
two or three uh in terms of what are the
current trends I think one thing that
has definitely stood out in the last two
years is attackers increasingly going
after bypassing multiactor
authentication and there is also a
reason for this right because um a lot
of Enterprises have started adopting MFA
as a standard practice because many
people would have read reports saying
you know MFA stops almost 90% of the
identity based attacks
right it's a very low investment High
return as a result what we have seen is
attackers innovating the techniques to
see how do they bypass multiactor
authentication so we have seen uh
increase in you know MFS spamming
attacks we have seen increase in voice
based fishing attacks uh we have also
seen you know very U significant uh
reputed companies uh falling for some of
the social engineering techniques like
you know attackers calling their it
departments and asking for a passwort
reset U or reset of some of the MF
factors and so on so that is one uh you
know interesting Trend um where the
attackers were successful you know not
in terms of volume but just in terms of
innovating and able to you know bypass
and create a lot of damage to uh the
companies uh maybe the second thing that
comes to my mind is the supply chain
attacks which where you know supply
chain attack is where an attacker to
infiltrate your network uh instead of
directly attacking your software and
your uh you know systems they would go
find a flaw in one of the vendor
softwares or a third party software that
that you are using in the network right
um so why it is uh signific signicantly
dangerous is because if let's say an
attacker is able to find uh a critical
bug let's say a remote code execution
bug in one of the vendor softwares now
this software might be deployed across
thousands of companies around the globe
right and by finding that one
vulnerability I can compromise all of
the companies that are using this and
there are lot of examples if we if we
turn back and see in the last one to two
years U and maybe U some of the audience
might recognize uh the a particular
Trend or vulnerability called Move It
software vulnerability so that was a
file transfer software that is used
extensively by many companies but there
was a SQL injection vulnerability that
has created Havoc for thousands of
companies right um just guess how much
uh amount of dollars was actually lost
because of this one single bug in in
move it can you let us know chart here
folks we're getting few interesting chat
replies here but can you let us know can
you
guess on chat yeah so this was this was
just one single vulnerability in one of
the file transfer software um it's a SQL
injection vulnerability that leads to
remote code execution
but if you have to guess you know an
approximate number of what was the loss
to the industry as a whole it was 1010
billion of uh amount and there were more
than thousand companies that got
compromised using this one single
vulnerability and this includes very big
names you know some of the Fortune 500
company names as well right so supply
chain on those lines is is very uh uh
deadly in terms of you know the damage
that it can create create right and
maybe the third thing is is the
ransomware trend ransomware is not a
recent Trend or current Trend as such it
has been there for the last few years
but again what we have seen in this
space is you
know shift from from typical encryption
based ransomware attacks to um
exfiltrating the data and holding the
companies at transom for not leaking the
sensitive information so those are some
of the current trends that uh we see and
looking forward U you know maybe couple
of things again in the interest of time
that I would like to share one is the
one of the worrisome Trends right now is
the emergence of cyber crime as a
service um some of the people in the
audience would have heard something
called Ras which is called ransomware as
a service similarly there is fishing as
a service there is malware as a service
uh so what this means is that you know
if I'm an attacker today and I do not
have the sophisticated level of
knowledge to go and write a malware to
attack you I can just go to one of the
you know dark websites pay $50 and get a
get a fishing kit or I pay a few
hundreds of dollars and get a ransom
work kit and I can get started right so
so this kind of you know reduces the
entry barrier for for an attacker to you
know come into this space and uh
somebody with no knowledge of uh you
know these malware and ransomware can
pull off a significant attack going
after some of the biggest companies in
the industry right so that is one of the
very worrisome Trends because now you
Enterprises have to fight with more
number of people uh because now they
have weaponry and Armory on their side
uh so that's one thing uh that I feel
will continue to increase and cause a
lot of problems in the coming years and
uh maybe the other part is the uh is
something that everybody's talking about
which is what can AI do in this space
right so there there's both sides to it
it can of course help the Defenders to
you know build right set of tools right
set of detections and and so on but it
is going to equally uh you
know weaponize some of the stuff that
attackers are doing today for example
the fishing males can be more deceiving
um you we have also we have already seen
one of the recent cases where you know
there was a deep fake voice fishing
meaning somebody can just deep fake your
voice yeah exactly and can call I think
yeah that that has happened like
basically you know to transfer the money
or I need this injur happen companies
also you know through a Founder
Founder's voice called through a
Founder's voice while you were speaking
Ro interesting message here on chat here
that I want to have Google Loa said but
I want to know like what is the reason
what would you get out of it please let
us know on chat here I think moving on
to the next question uh how are
organizations crafting strategies to
mitigate these risk which we talked
about yeah so I I think there are many
strategies but uh you know if I take a
step back and think about it um the post
one of the important impacts of the
pandemic is um the company is opening up
for remote work right how do they enable
uh remote work for their employees
that's one and second Trend that has
emerged after pandemic is you
know how can they accelerate their Cloud
Journey right from from the on premise
uh infrastructure they have a lot of
companies started to migrate to Cloud it
was happening even prior to the pandemic
but just that it it was done in a much
more uh unprepared and accelarated way
right after the pandemic uh given the
situ ations couple of years back so
because of these reasons as well as the
other trends that we talked about uh one
of the significant Frameworks that lot
of companies or models or architecture
whatever you call it uh one of the
things that companies are investing is
called the zero trust model where uh if
I have to put it in simple words um
earlier you know companies used to have
all of their data uh assets employees in
the corporate Network like everybody
used to come to office and all the tools
used to be deployed within the corporate
Network and we monitor what's going in
and out and that's how we used to
measure uh how secure we are but with
Cloud everything has just scattered
right like a lot of people teams don't
even know where their infrastructure is
currently running um so zero trust kind
of addresses these scenarios right so it
basically uh is a model that Advocates
irrespective of where the uh user is
signing in from they could be in office
they could be somewhere remote zero TR
presents a model where um the access is
given only after proper uh verification
of identity only if the device is
compliant and it also talks about some
of the measures like segmenting the
network so that the blast radius is
smaller in terms of in in case of a
compromise uh and and so on so zero
trust is definitely one important thing
and uh we also talked about the attacks
on MFA so a lot of people are now
talking about fish resistant credentials
and implementing pedo based
authentication as well um so these are
the two things that come to my mind
awesome awesome that sounds pretty
interesting and what impact is this
having on the demand for cyber Security
Experts yeah so I think again if I just
just zoom out of whatever we talked
about until now right and if we talk
about hey what was the impact of
everything that was happening you know
companies lost money there were attacks
from one nation against other Nation to
perform cyber Espionage uh and so on so
looking at all of these you know one
thing we could definitely understand is
cyber security is not just a technical
problem anymore right it's more of a
business problem it's more of an
Enterprise problem it's more of a nation
state problem so the problem is very
real right um so on those lines
definitely there's going to be a need
for the right set of people to solve
this problem and and the problem is
multifold right in terms of how do we
protect the asserts to how do we remain
compliant to how do we uh you know
detect and respond to the attacks to how
do we maintain and measure our risk
posture there are many facets to cyber
security um so the demand is definitely
there um but one thing that I would like
to add here is uh we have been talking
about the shortage of cyber Security
Professionals in the industry for quite
some time I'm sure a lot of people have
seen multiple reports um and news
articles talking about the shortage um
the shortage is is is is true but I
think the shortage also is in terms of
finding the right talent for these
positions that are there right so it is
important to understand that uh number
numbers is one thing but we which is the
quantity aspect right but if we also we
also have to look at the Quality aspect
of it like there might be X number of
positions that are required in the
industry but what sort of positions are
we talking about what sort of skills is
the industry looking at so looking at
both of these in conjunction will give
the uh right output in terms of what is
the demand and what kind of demand
exists for uh the right set of roles and
and and
jobs uh I I thank you so much for
answering that uh R we have gotten an
interesting question related to your
journey here if you can look at the Q&A
I'll just send that to you on the chat
here as well because we have a lot of
questions in the Q&A might be hard to
find so I'll just ping you the question
here on chat so uh like this person I
think can you name yourself as well on
chat here so can you share the journey
and experience of learning a job at
Microsoft what advice would you like to
give me if I want to be at Microsoft in
next two to three years I think should
have specified what category of stream
this person would want to go in can let
us know on chat okay yeah reped reped on
chat okay the can you let us know what
exactly uh s
so
okay yeah you want you want me to take
it rasa right now sure sure yeah yeah so
so yeah I mean this is one of the
questions that I very often encounter in
my uh LinkedIn uh you know chats as well
so I I I can answer it in a very generic
terms right not just Microsoft but let's
say if you are trying to or if you're
aspiring to get into any of the you know
Technology based uh product based
companies um at least from my experience
of going through the Journey as well as
speaking to some of the other people who
have been through the Journey in various
other similar companies I can probably
share two or three things that might be
helpful um first thing is it's it's
super important to have the foundations
right the security
foundations um I have never uh you know
looked at what are the job postings and
how do I build the skill set so I always
went by whatever stuff I have been doing
for I joined Microsoft after I think six
and a half to seven years of my career
so until that point I have always tried
to you know get in depth Hands-On
understanding of the work that I have
been I have done until that point so
this includes you know web application
testing uh uh and threat modeling and
other things that I talked about so
getting the foundations right is very
very important uh because if your
foundations are strong then you could
build uh lot of stuff on top of it right
it's like a building right so the the
higher you want to go the deeper the
foundation should be uh when the
foundation lead so that's one second
thing is the Practical Hands-On skill
set um what I have been tested mostly in
my my interviews is not U uh on the
lines of uh tell me the definition of
XYZ uh stuff right it is more on the
lines of scenarios if you encounter this
scenario what Would You Do
Right For example let's say
maybe if there are some folks from web
application security they might be able
to relate so some somebody might ask hey
what is cross-side scripting right so if
you read an article about cross side
scripting you'll be able to answer that
question question but if there is a
question that is on the lines of uh
within cross side scripting uh if if the
developer
is is already measuring the is already
validating the input on so and so lines
and so and so ways how do you think the
attacker will bypass this right so that
specific knowledge you know you will be
able to gain when you do a lot of
Hands-On and practical skill set so I
think that is the other part that was uh
pretty helpful for me and third thing
also is is import is giving equal
importance to the non-technical skill
set uh along with the technical skill
set right so whatever you are doing you
should be able to articulate and suggest
and um sometimes propose what other
improvements can be made to the process
and things like that right so sometimes
um you know these other skills are
equally measured along with the
technical skill set that people might
have um so those are few things that I
feel have uh helped me in my journey uh
in in making it to the Microsoft
Pyon uh that sounds pretty interesting a
lot of hard work I must say with uh in
your journey I hope T that answers your
question uh let us know on chat here for
folks while you speaking we getting a
lot of mess on chat here a lot of
questions please do put put down your
questions on the chat here uh I think
moving on to the next question uh for
those uh aspiring to embark on a career
in cyber security uh what guidance can
be offered on selecting a specific Niche
uh within this
field yeah so so I think uh so if
they're already embarking on the journey
so first thing I would say is um
developing as much awareness as possible
on the breadth and depth of the domain
is is very important because cyber
security is a notion right uh it's it's
it's pretty deep in terms of depth and
it's pretty broad as well um so if you
just talk about hey what domains exist
there are so many domains right
application security network security uh
security operations incident response
threat hunting threat detection security
engineering you know I can go on and on
there are so many uh domains now a role
in let's say as a soft analyst in soof
team is going to be extremely different
and varied from a role of let's say a
security architect who is you know
looking at the design of the security uh
security of the applications so the
roles and responsibilities also vary
drastically based on uh the roles within
cyber security right and again there are
teams within same space like if you take
security operations as a space uh there
is a tier one analyst role there is a
threat Hunter role there is an incident
responder role there is a seam engineer
role so again based on where you are the
roles and responsibilities will again
significantly differ uh so I think one
of the things that uh that's important
to uh do is to understand what are your
interest areas what are your some of the
strength areas and which one aligns to
you U these domains that I talked
about either the domains or the jobs
that are present Within These domains
which one closely aligns to your
interest and passion uh and then seeking
some of those related roles would be a
good start if you're trying to navigate
you know how do how do I start and where
do I go from here maybe that that would
be a way to just quickly uh get
started uh awesome thank you for
answering that uh we have gotten a very
relevant question to career in cyber
security I'll just share with you on
chat here because the Q&A box is full
now I think it'll be hard to find that
question uh so uh rooh abijit has asked
that hi Rohit after pursuing entry level
certifications uh okay so sorry not that
one I think someone while I was
messaging only people are like scamming
the chat please folks put down your
questions in the Q&A box we'll get
confused okay uh this is from abijit uh
and uh if I want to start in the cyber
security domain uh what profile can I
apply for and I have 10 years of
experience in the administration
including server and
network yeah so again like I said in the
in the beginning of the discussion right
so if you have let's say uh an existing
skill set in this case I think you
talked about system administration or
maybe server
Administration um so you will have
to I mean my advice would be you know
try to see what is the closest
domain in cyber security that matches to
your existing skill set so if you're
talking about system administration
let's say so if you have a good
understanding of the host level details
the operating system level stuff uh some
of the processes that exist within the
system Etc then a natural progression to
cyber security would be to understand uh
you know and and look at some of the
roles within the Security operation
space because
uh a lot of analysis that happens in
security investigations is at an
endpoint level or at a host level uh so
if you already have an existing
knowledge of the host
then topping it up with with knowledge
of you know security Ops uh and malware
analysis Etc might be a good way to look
at it uh but again this is a very very
individualistic uh question in my
opinion because uh what you want to
pursue in the next few years is very
much dependent on you know whether you
are inclined in one line of path versus
the other right for example like I
mentioned the sock role that I just
talked about also comes with um other
aspects like you know people usually
typically work in shifts um and you know
you have incidents coming in back to
back it's a high volume High stressful
area and uh you know there is an
attacker who is doing something
something and the responsibility is on
you on that particular day to take the
right action to stop them right so some
people enjoy being in that space and
some people may not really enjoy uh the
same line of work um so whatever
decision that you take uh which is why I
started with you know build as much
awareness as possible on what does the
role entail right and lot of information
is already available over internet you
could just search and find out but you
could also you know reach out to people
talk to people uh over LinkedIn uh to
get a better understanding or if you
know somebody in your uh company who is
in the security space you would approach
them and talk to them as well right yeah
uh and also there are networking events
like like like the webinar that we are
doing as well as other networking events
that happen like there is nullcon that
happens in India OAS chapter meets that
happen in local chapter uh in each of
the Cities so all of these are different
Avenues to understand and develop that
awareness and once you feel hey this
makes better sense then you could you
could take that
plunge I think someone just asked like
you know how do you keep updating
yourself within the cyber security I
think you answered few few things you
can do right so that's great uh I think
we've talked about the careers in cyber
security Now moving on to the skills so
what specific skill sets are
organization seeking when recruiting for
cyber security roles
today so uh once again right uh so if I
have maybe we could talk about this in
two different ways right so what one is
what is the minimum Baseline skills that
you might want to Target and then what
are some of the specific skills that
might be required for those roles
depending on those roles right um so if
you're talking about any cyber security
role at a at a very um fundamental level
um some of the basic skill sets would be
to have a good understanding of the
operating systems um to have a good
understanding of the networking and
networking protocols
and how communication happens in general
over web uh
between you know systems in on premise
and systems in Cloud Etc uh cryptography
uh basics of cryptography basics of
identity active directory right because
these things that I just talked about
will keep popping up in any and every
domain that we uh go to right in the
next phase so having a good not a very
deep understanding but at least having a
good basic level 100 understanding of
some of these Concepts that I just
talked about is going to be definitely
helpful and on top of it you know
depending on the role that ex that we
are talking about the skill set may vary
right so some roles might might be very
U heavy on understanding of the cloud
security part or some roles might
require deeper understanding of the how
do we investigate uh part and some roles
might be uh heavy on in terms of
understanding the programming and and
the design and and the flow of data
between different components for design
reviews and so on so two ways of looking
at it one is the baseline or the basic
skill set and then what is the specific
skill set for that
role uh thank you so much for answering
that RIT uh so while you were speaking
so we have gotten a really active
audience great audience here in they are
actually having their own conversation
on cyber security they're helping each
other out while you're speaking about
you know having a mentor or you know
going and attending more sessions you
getting more knowledgeable I can see
that happening on the chat where you
were speaking so we can see that Spirit
you know here for cyber security uh I
think uh we will talk more about a lot
of questions we have gotten in the Q&A
box uh so moving on um so we have talked
about the skills and we have talked
about the career paths you can take up
we have talked about what exactly cyber
security companies are looking for you
know when basically uh you want to
basically Aspire in for becoming a
cybercity expert so what exactly is
stopping you for becoming a cybercity
expert you can see a quick pull on your
screen this is a multiple choice
question so you can select multiple
options because there can be multiple
concerns right when you are basically
thinking of aspiring for a service SEC
career so you are here because you are
interested in cice security career and I
can definitely make make that out from
the chat here I can see a lot of folks
basically helping each other out with
aners uh like in trying to basically
engage as well you know while Rohit was
speaking and uh we have gotten a lot of
questions in the Q&A box we'll be taking
those uh very very soon uh so meanwhile
uh folks you can let us know what is the
biggest challenge when it comes to
becoming a cyber security expert here
you can see four quick options here uh
the first one being I can't find a
program with a fully comprehensive
curriculum and the second one I don't
have the Practical exposure I need to
become job ready uh third one I find it
difficult to learn from pre-recorded
videos uh fourth one my work schedule
won't allow me enough time for learning
so I can see while I was speaking most
of the folks have already shared uh
their challenges here on the poll here
in case this this particular poll does
not cover your answer you can let us
know on chat here what is the biggest
challenge you know when it comes to
becoming a cyber security expert so I'll
just give like 10 seconds more for the
poll for a few of the folks who
basically asked still thinking about it
uh so meanwhile um for folks who have
already put down a questions in the Q&A
box that's great we'll be taking those
with pretty soon and uh I think
someone's asked about the webinar
recording so you in case you want to go
through the session again you we will be
sending you a followup email with the
recording link so you can basically
check that out and basically go to the
session again in case you want
to if you have missed the session so I
think I can see that folks have already
shared the respon responses on the chart
here I can see most of them so I'll just
quickly end the PLL in 5 seconds so 5 4
3 2 1 let me quickly end the poll and
share the results with you folks so we
can see that we have gotten the highest
amount of votes here 52% uh for I
wouldn't get the Practical exposure I
need to become job ready and the second
one I can't find a fully program with a
fully comprehensive curriculum and we
gotten few words for I find it difficult
to learn from pre-recorded videos and
last one I Works will won't allow me
enough time for learning so now moving
on to the program introduction here so
the triple it is Bangalore advanc
executive program in cice security uh
comes with a comprehensive curriculum
with industry align learning path uh it
comes with integrated case studies hat
on projects for practical experience
which R had mentioned which is very
important you know when you basically
are going towards a cyber security
career and you're very new to it so
having a Hands-On project for practical
experience is really required and also
online live virtual classrooms with peer
and instructor interactions uh this
program will be flexible to fit your
Lifest and schedule in case you are a
working professional which we saw you
know from initial votes of folks who
have joined most of them are like you
know having more than five years of
experience and uh the program duration
for this one is six months you can just
complete it by giving 10 hours per week
moving on uh and and what exactly will
begin getting from this program so uh
you can see here two certificates so you
will be getting one certificate from
triple IB cyber security program
certificate uh on the advanced executive
program in cyber security and uh one you
will be getting from npci cyber security
virtual internship certificate uh and
also uh the Hands-On learning uh with
eight plus projects in this program
which you can add into your profile and
enhance it and also ncpi cyber security
virtual inter internship which I
discussed about and also master classes
with tripleb and npci experts uh the
simply learn job assist career Services
I'll be talking more about it in the
upcoming slides moving on the triple it
be Advantage so in International
Institute of Information Technology
Bangalore was established in 1998 and uh
basically it basically is one of the
most reputated it education research
enterpreneurship and Innovation uh
institutes in India and uh basically
Partnerships they have with corporate
sector as well so having a triple ITB uh
you know uh basically program in your
resume will completely enhance enance
your resume when you are basically going
out there and applying for jobs in cyber
security now I think someone asked about
the eligibility of this program so uh
you need to have a bachelor's degree
with 50% or higher marks and uh minimum
one of one year of experience is
required for this program and also basic
understanding of programming concept
helps right I think Rohit has mentioned
that as well before so how this program
basically prepares you so uh the how the
program builds your cyber security
skills step by step I'll take through
those so we start with orientation
session for advanced executive program
and uh we then cover the Enterprise
infrastructure security and moving on to
the application and uh web application
security and then we cover ransomware
and malware analysis and ethical hacking
and bapd and also cyber security virtual
internship which I basically mentioned
earlier by NBCI uh also we have
electrics in this program uh tripleb
cber security master classes Out
Security ccsp uh security governments
and Frameworks so electives are optional
uh you don't have to pay anything extra
for that basically they come as a part
of the program so uh it is up to you if
you want to take them
up and also you get to master over in
demand cyber security tools like C NX uh
kuu metas flit openvas nesses UB to and
map and many more inbar cyber Securities
in this program also I think we
mentioned about the virtual cyber
security internship here to which you
can showcase to your future employes
here uh in this virtual internship you
will be learning how to build solutions
to problems that MIM make real life
business scenarios for True experience
for someone who's coming from a non-
cyber security background this virtual
internship will be really helpful and
the certificate as well from npci so uh
we also have a simply n community that
basically supports you the learner has
access to the instructor program manager
has a cohort manager learning teams and
peers and curriculum
resources we have global leaders as
program advisers in this program uh
Professor V SAR Professor sh Shas VI and
Professor uh chandri Kuran being one of
them they make sure that simply Learners
is delivering as per standards to Triple
IAT these program uh also I think I
mentioned the job assist Services by IM
jobs here so we have partnered with IM
jobs uh for this program where you get
access to job portal resume review and
rewrite services and one-on-one
interview services through this program
which basically will help you enhance
your portfolio and also will get you job
ready when you're getting out there you
know after the program and trying to
basically you know score a job score
your dream job uh this basically job
assist Services by imjs will definitely
help so uh let us know are you
interested in enrolling into the cyber
security uh program by triple ITB uh
this Advanced executive program in cyber
security uh we have talked about the
skills we have talked about the carers
talked about the handson projects you'll
be getting to you know cover in this
program also uh we have talked about the
as I said career skills and programs
you'll be covering in this program and
also the certificates for the virtual
internship you will be getting from npci
uh so uh what exactly is stopping you so
you can see a quick poll here on the
screen here so you can see would you
like to enroll into the advanced
executive cyber security program by
tripleb and there are two bck options
there yes or no you can let us know
there and also just to let you know
folks for attending this webinar here uh
we have a special bonus offer for you uh
so I would recommend not to miss out on
the bonus offer here because we do that
pretty rarely in these webinars you know
when we do and uh you can basically uh
Avail the bonus offer here on the
program here as well so um again like
I'll just keep this poll live for 10
seconds more I can see most of the folks
have already shared interest here uh
towards enrollment so that's great and
also I can see the Q&A box popping up
here with a lot of questions here we'll
be taking those pretty soon here for
folks basically who we have not been
able to address their queries as I as I
promised you earlier that will have a
special duration for the Q&A part so
I'll just give 10 seconds more for the
poll here meanwhile what we can do is uh
if you have any questions if you already
done with the poll here you can put down
any questions in the Q&A box so please
utilize this time meanwhile let's
quickly browse through what questions we
have gotten here I'll be taking you
through the enrollment steps and the
upcoming cohorts and the program free
after this after this basically
enrollment poll here so let me give like
five seconds more for a few of the folks
who basically are yet to basically share
their interest in enrollment into the
advanced cyber security program by
triple
ITV I can see pole the poll is still
moving in uh so what we can do is we can
wait for like 5 Seconds more I can see
few of the folks are still thinking
about it most of the folks I can see 80%
of the folks have already shared
interest so that's great and also while
we were having a conversation uh I saw a
lot of questions on the chat here as
well so just for you folks like please
go and put on your question to the chat
as you can see there are so many
messages on chat here
right awesome awesome uh I think I'll
just give five seconds more so let me
quickly end the poll in 5 seconds so I
would basically just uh tell people few
of the folks who have yet to vote for
the poll you see on the screen here so
again like would you like to enroll into
the advanced cyber security uh program
by triple ITV you can see a quick pull
on your screen here with two options yes
or
no okay I can see most of the folks have
already shared their words so I'll get
just 5 Seconds more so 5 4 3 2 1 let me
quickly end up B and thank you so much
for sharing your interest towards
enrollment for folks who have shared and
uh let me quickly take you through the
enrollment steps here uh so there are
very three simple easy steps you need to
follow for enrollment uh so the step one
submit an application uh to us at ask us
simple.net I'll share that email ID here
on chat and based on the application you
submit you your application will be
going for a review based on the
qualifications I've shared the
eligibility and prequisites and based on
that you be getting an admissions off a
letter call from Simply learns learning
consultant uh in case you want to go
through the program you know um you need
more help assistance that is something
I'll be asking you know towards the end
of the program uh moving on the program
fee and schedule so the program fee for
this one is 1 54,9 199 including taxes
Ina and uh we have financing option
available as well for Emi as low as
5,275 rupees per month uh for folks who
want to check out the program fee for
their own regions because I saw a lot of
folks have joined from different
different uh countries as well I'll just
quickly share the link to the program
here so you can see the program fee for
your own region as well I'm just sharing
the link here on chat you can check out
the details in much more
detail and also uh about the email here
uh if basically if you have any
questions about the program if you need
more assistance you can always reach out
to us at ask us at simple.net uh the
next cohort for this one uh is starting
on 30th of October the classes start on
30th of October and the welcome sessions
will be starting on 25th of October and
as I said that we if you need any help
any assistance you can always reach out
to us at ask us at s. I've shared that
on the chat here and also just to let
you know that we only take like 25 to 30
folks per coh so in order to make sure
you're getting all the attention that is
required in this program by triple ITB
uh so uh we have very limited seats in
this upcoming cohort so for that uh we
would want to know that when exactly are
you planning to uh enroll into the
program so I'll just uh relaunch the
poll here once again so uh you can see a
quick poll on your screen for folks who
have already shared their interest uh
towards enrollment to the program please
do let us know when do you plan to
enroll uh this will give us
understanding when exactly we need to
reach out to you and also you'll be
getting a bonus offer for attending this
webinar so I would recommend if you're
still thinking about it you're not sure
when exact exactly do you want to start
maybe within three months within six
months more than six months from now I
would recommend to choose any of the
options here later options if you are
still basically planning you're not sure
when to start uh because if you choose
any of the options you will still be
basically getting to Avail the bonus
office for the webinar here for the
program so I can see while I was
speaking the polls started moving so
that's great I'll give 10 seconds more
for the folks here before we end this
poll and move on to the Q&A part of the
session
also uh we basically are right on time
we just have like few more minutes left
where we can cover like you know uh as
many Q&A questions as possible so let me
just quickly end this poll in 10 seconds
here so please for a few of the folks
who basically have shared already shared
with us you know the they want to enroll
into the program please do let us know
when do you plan to enroll this will
definitely give us understanding when to
reach out to you awesome I think I'll
just close this p in 5 Seconds of 5 4 3
2 1 thank you so much for sharing that
with us now moving on to the Q&A part of
the session uh so we have Rohit back
with us uh let me just quickly scroll
through the Q&A box here um just to let
you know we have plenty of questions
here uh we'll try to cover as many as
possible relevant
ones
okay okay a lot of questions here a lot
of questions just looking through it you
can still go and put on your questions
in the Q&A
box okay I think roit we can see one
question from hajira zamin shik uh I am
from a management background where do I
see myself in this cyber security
career
so just so that I understand the
question maybe the the person who put it
might be asking if I'm purely from a
management background then what kind of
roles can I look at is that a right
understanding yeah
exactly they can let us know on chat
here as well you know ha you can let us
know on chart here as well while Ro is
basically you know answering your
question so that will be helpful yeah so
see I mean um most of the roles in cyber
security have some sort of technical
flavor to it right because just based on
the domain itself that everything
starting from something as uh as
specific as investigations to something
little generic right like Risk
Management Etc all of them have some
sort of technical flavor to it uh but
there might be variations in terms of
you know certain roles might demand
extremely specific Niche and
specific skill sets whereas some roles
might might be you know little relaxing
in terms of uh you know the
technicalities of what level of
knowledge is required in in such roles
um so again I'm sure that when um we say
you know with with management experience
there it comes with some sort of
experience in the other domain as well
right it could be um programming if not
programming you know even if it's about
um let's say if the if the domain is
tied to healthcare for instance right
which is a very generic domain it's not
related to programming or anything as
such uh there are specific security
roles which are domain based as well um
if you are familiar with the some of the
compliance and risk related um
regulations that impact Healthcare uh
then that might be a good opportunity
right so one pivot ised to see um like
the earlier version of what we talked
about uh programming networking system
administration Incident Management etc
etc how do I build on top of it the
other pivot is to see the domain itself
right am I in the banking sector am I in
the insurance sector am I in the
healthcare sector and for those Ro
sectors there are different laws and
different uh acts uh which have a
security flavor and security role so
those might be something worth looking
at if if you're not specifically looking
at uh you know roles with very high um
level of technical flavor to
it uh thank you so much Rohit for
answering that Haj let us know on chart
here uh if that answers your question
arbas I can find a question in the Q&A
box please do put down your question
there uh also let's take the next
question here this is by dipika arit uh
I am an office uh 365 edmin uh working
on email security gateways which role
would be suitable for me in cyber
security it's a perfect question I think
the question has the answer so email
based there are so many email based
vectors right fishing uh and so on so uh
usually sock tier one analyst roles
involve looking at the fishing alerts
and tring them and responding to those
attacks which includes again a cycle of
Investigations containment remediation
and so on so if you are already familiar
with some of the email systems and how
they work um then learning about fishing
and ack um analyst role would be a very
uh close probable role and and of course
there there is also a different flavor
to it right so there's a lot of research
happening on on the SEC security product
side on how do we identify and uh block
these email based vectors that are
coming up uh so if if you are inclined
towards performing
research um then security researcher
roles are also very uh close to this but
but again so you will not find a lot of
such roles right because the number of
products that exist at at an email
monitoring level and the number of roles
that might be open for um security
research in that space will be very
narrow and very specific so that's the
caveat uh thank you so much Rit for
answering that I hope the pi that
answers your question please do let us
know on chat here I think we'll just
take one last question Rohit uh I put
that on the chat for you so uh this is
Sachin uh Sachin uh says that I have
around 20 years of experience in
industrial control system uh working as
manager in my current organization uh do
you think it is worthwhile for me to
shift to cyber security and what is the
way well see again uh we talked about
this just few minutes back right so
whether you should shift into that role
or not is is a very individual based
question right it depends on what your
aspirations passions and interest uh
interest uh levels are um but but given
your background if you are asking hey
Will Will there be some sort of a roles
uh that I could look at in cyber
security definitely yes right will uh do
you want to pursue your career let's say
in the next 10 years within that line of
work um that requires more conversation
and understanding of the profile and the
career development plan and so on so
I'll I'll just leave it there that uh it
is possible if if you are really looking
at spending next few years then
absolutely
yes um that sounds pretty interesting
thank you so much R for answering that
we do have like a lot of questions on
the Q&A box but I think you have
answered most of them most of them being
like you know they're coming from a non
technical background you know going to
cyber security I think you have cleared
that in the initial conversation we had
so we will end this session now uh
before that we just want to know that do
you need assistance uh while in loaning
into the programs you can see a quick
full question here and also I'm pretty
sure guys uh you know uh like if you
have any questions uh Rohit can they
reach out to you like uh if you can
basically let them know where they can
connect with you or you know follow you
because they're very curious to know
what exactly you follow what exactly you
know you watch so I think that will be a
good idea as well right so absolutely
I'll put my LinkedIn Link in the in the
chat I'm usually active on LinkedIn so
if there is uh um there are any
questions and if you want to connect
then please feel free to do so I'll try
to respond to as many folks as possible
but uh also uh you know give it sometime
in case you don't hear from me
immediately awesome awesome awesome uh
uh awesome you can put that on the chart
here meanwhile you can see a quick pull
on your screen here do you need
assistance enroll into the program this
is for folks who have already shared
interest towards enrollment and also
have let us know when do they plan to
enroll so please do let us know I would
say take the extra help right if you're
getting the extra help why not uh about
the program so I'll just keep this P
alive for five seconds more I can see
folks have already shared uh their
responses on the chat here and Rohit has
shared his LinkedIn here as well on chat
so in case you want to connect he has a
interesting profile on LinkedIn by the
way and he basically keeps posting
reposting a lot of good stuff so I think
a lot of your questions basically what
Rohit watches what Rohit reads what what
does he like I think you can follow him
to get to know more and also we have a
lot of upcoming sessions with Rohit in
the coming months as well so this is not
the last one you'll get to see him more
in the upcoming sessions with simply
learn so that also will be there so
thank you so much and I'll just end this
poll here uh we are towards the end of
the session so first of all thank you so
much Rohit first of all you know
answering so many questions lat to cyber
security and taking us through cyber
security careers and sharing your
journey with us here would you like to
say something the audience before we end
the session I'm glad to be here thank
you so much Rasha and thanks for simply
learn for inviting me today and thanks a
lot for all the uh all the people who
joined and for being extremely
interactive uh it's it's it's fantastic
to take some time off and really good
audience I must say really good audience
Interactive you have gotten here uh for
cyber security cyber security definitely
is some some interesting field you know
where people basically want to shift
their careers too I think we'll be
talking about more about it in the
coming months you know if we we'll be
having session with you maybe on Trends
or you know indry tends or something
like that I think we'll we won't reveal
it right now right away but you can
basically follow Rohit you know on Ling
to know more basically share we'll be
sharing an update there as well so thank
you so much folks you have been a great
audience and uh would love to see see
you in upcoming cyber security sessions
here and also maybe in a program cohart
as well if you join thank you so much
thank you we'll be ending the session
now
uh have a good evening good morning you
know wherever you're joining us from
good afternoon thank you thank
you also I think someone asked about the
post webinar survey so when I end the
webinar now you will be getting a post
webinar survey so thank you so much a
great audience and would love to see you
in
uping and also please do that and I see
a lot of appreciation still coming in
for the speaker here with us that's
great uh in case you want the recording
also you'll be getting that over mail
you want to check it out you can go and
do that as well so awesome thank you so
much folks we'll be ending the session
now thank you once
again